this week we heard the news that the
guard has laid off its entire creative
and production team it's devastating
news for those affected by this and if
you're starting to notice a trend here
in Esports well you're not wrong
[Music]
so obviously this is a pretty big story
in Esports this week and we do cover
these kinds of stories as and when they
happen so if you want to stay up to date
with all of them then make sure you're
subscribed to the score Esports Channel
and if you like the video give it a like
as well thank you so the guard this orc
has had an explosive past year to say
the least this time last year they were
a newly formed valoran roster who had
only been training together for just a
few months they then had their now
famous fairy tale run at Challengers one
and to say they beat expectations would
be a gross understatement after toppling
the likes of Sentinels and Cloud9 the
guard cemented their arrival in valoran
with a grand final win over optic what
is this a Divine Comedy for Dante's
Inferno by sire player 1v1 with crown
and a lot of these breakout performances
could be attributed to Trent The Prodigy
who facilitated so much of that early
success yes does he import and now the
shocked
are going to play Legolas and Tourette
stays alive now look at the HP it's a
1v2 and it's doable he spots out one
wall Bank where is it it's a possibility
he finds it and now it's a one versus
one
unaware of the position of the other
last known in close to single bullet to
reveal a little bit
print but the guards struggled to keep
that momentum going throughout 2022.
despite being the ones to watch at
Masters Reykjavik they were knocked out
in the lower bracket round one by paper
Rex they also missed the chance to
compete in Champions after being swept
3-0 by a hundred thieves in North
America's Last Chance qualifier despite
reports last summer that they've been
shortlisted to be a part of the new
franchise VCT model they failed to make
the cut and have been competing this
year in the challenges circuit and so
far fans have been pleased to see the
team take a 2-0 lead in the group stage
but this week's news hasn't just put a
damper on their success it's thrown some
question marks over the entire orc on
Wednesday an apparel designer for the
guard tweet them out that quote
everyone's position at the guard has
been eliminated Esports and streaming
reporter Hunter specified that the
layoffs had solely affected the guards
content social talent and creative teams
as the evening went on we heard from
more and more now former guard employees
sharing similar stories of being
abruptly let go from the org with little
to no warning perhaps the most Stark
example came from Ariel Ben Abraham who
was the newly appointed GM of apparel at
the guard he said he moved location for
this job earlier this week only to find
himself unemployed two days later he
said he faced difficulty from HR staff
at the office and that he was now trying
to get out of his lease in what feels
like a pretty confusing situation all
round one thing appears to be certain
that this whole thing went down quite
abruptly graphic designer George Nowak
told Esports GG that it was the exact
opposite to when he lost his job at 100
thieves he said their HR team helped him
find a new job by advising him on salary
negotiations and wording replies to
potential job offers with the guard
George said they were just eager to push
people out of the door now at the moment
it does look like these layoffs have not
affected the guard's competitive teams
and this seemed to be confirmed on
stream Yesterday by one of their Apex
Legends players ramboski guard wants to
move kind of out of the content side of
things and focus more on competitive Bo
added that the guard wanted to keep them
but that they are now allowed to look
around for other teams yesterday dot
Esports reported that the guard's
valorant roster is remaining with the
org for now while the Esports Advocate
stated the same is true for the Los
Angeles gorillas and Los Angeles
Gladiators their Call of Duty and
OverWatch teams respectively so it's all
a bit of a mess right now and once again
the conversation has sprung up about
what or even who is to blame for this
sort of thing some people are pointing
to franchising being the cause and
there's certainly an argument for that a
franchise League provides stability for
investors to throw their money behind
the teams that make it but it's
obviously much more difficult for those
like the guard who don't make the cut
now Riot did create the Challenger's
Ascension tournament as a path for teams
that didn't make franchising to climb
their way up to Tier 1 baloran but
having a presence in tier one
competition or even the opportunity to
eventually get there might only be half
the story last week our very own Keith
capstick outlined how after 100 thieves
announced layoffs within their content
team orgs are looking for revenue
streams outside of competition
altogether and this is where things get
complicated for me because as someone
who creates YouTube content in Esports I
don't want to see anyone losing their
jobs on the other hand if nadeshot and
his executive team believe that there's
no path to profitability in Partnerships
and content creation even if it is more
lucrative in the short term then they
absolutely should pivot because if they
don't make the change then eventually
the whole company will lose their jobs
in the gods case there's naturally a lot
of finger pointing going on people feel
a deep sense of empathy with these
talented individuals who provide the
interface with these kinds of Orcs you
know these orgs through their content
production these people are the ones
that create that Gateway of interaction
through their videos graphics and talent
management and so naturally that they
can morph into anger and a desire to
know who is to blame some will pin this
on the likes of Stan kronke the
billionaire owner of KSC the company
that owns the guard among many other
professional sports teams such as the
Los Angeles Rams the Denver Nuggets and
Arsenal Football Club the feeling among
some is that although yes Esports orgs
are expensive and may take inordinate
amounts of time and creative Endeavors
to make them even close to profitable
billionaires like Stan kronki are the
exact kind of people who can fund that
he's worth 12.89 billion dollars it
would literally cost 0.01 billion to
keep the guard going for five years
which he has this is a lie I edited this
he's worth 12.9 billion dollars no one
wanted
he even left
Esports which is raising a lot of
concerns Ludwig who recently became an
owner of an Esports orc himself describe
what we're seeing now as the winter of
Esports that people have been predicting
for years the bursting of the
speculative bubble if you will and these
kind of cuts do seem to back that up
what's happened at the guard is just the
latest in what's sadly become an
increasingly more common occurrence
within Esports whatever the cause for
all this it's undoubtedly more complex
than any single factor it's likely a
combination of each exacerbating the
next it's easy to get caught up in this
sort of top-down analysis after all it's
an industry that a lot of people you and
I included are emotionally invested or
even employed in but for now a lot of
the focus I'm seeing in the community is
on the people the actual humans who have
been affected by these sorts of layoffs
the creative teams who lost their jobs
at the guard are the latest collateral
damage from factors beyond their control
in Esports and there's a sense that this
trend will only continue
foreign
[Music]